تتصاعد وحده القصف على منطقه خرسون لاسيما
الضفه اليمنى حيث تتمركز القوات
الاوكرانيه هذا اليوم تعرضت المدينه لقصف
صاروخي عنيف ادى الى مقتل سته اشخاص في
ضربه صاروخيه واحده اصابت مناطق سكنيه
وكذلك مناطق يوجد بها متاجر
للمواطنين نشاهد في هذه الاثناء كيف تقوم
اجهزه الانقاذ
والاسعاف بانتشال جثتين لمدنيين سقطاب في
هذا المكان اثناء تواجدهما خلال النهار في
هذه المنطقه التي تعرضت لقصف عنيف
بصواريخ من طراز جراد في ضربه صاروخيه
مكثفه شهدتها منطقه خرسون هذه الضفه
اليمنى من جانب الضفه اليسرى فيما كذلك
شهدت تعدت المناطق سكنيه واحياء
يتواجد بها مدنيون قصف شديد بالمدفعيه
وكذلك بالصواريخ فيما تتواصل الضربات
الصاروخيه والمدفعيه على هذه المنطقه
بينما ايضا تسمع بين الحين والاخر اصوات
الانفجارات عند الضفه اليسرى حيث تتمركز
ايضا القوات
الروسيه الان سمعنا ايضا صوت قصف جديد هذا
يعني ان القصف متبادل بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه وان هذه
الوتيره بدات ترتفع بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والقوات الروسيه هنا عند منطقه خرسون وهذا
المحور المشتعل فيما ايضا القصف كان قد
طال مناطق في مقاطعه زابروجيا وكذلك
جنوبيه مقاطعه حسن
مسعود الجزيره خرسون